you know it's not necessarily that we
want
men you know to be completely feminine i
think it's just more like
you know we would just like them to be a
little more considerate
yeah
no the only th the reason why i'm i've
in my personal point of view why women
want men to be more
effeminate is so women can control them
i don't think it's the femininity women
want to con
this new generation of women wants to
control
of course you can so i don't think you
want to fight
bet okay i'll win go on you you really
want but go on
um i don't think it's that we want to
win in the femininity i think it's just
more like
to understand like our perspective and
like you know you're [ __ ] making me
forget what the [ __ ] i'm about to say
just be more like considerate and like
[Music]
we don't want you guys to be like our
girlfriends or whatever
we just want you guys to understand
why we're saying some things and you
know why something sometimes you guys
the way you guys do things make us feel
a certain way okay
when you know we're on our [ __ ]
period and you say oh you feel this way
because you're on your period like [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] say that
just be like other you you're not
understanding how men think you're
really not understanding how men but
okay but then why should women always be
the people that try to understand what
you guys think why can't you guys try to
understand what the [ __ ] we're trying to
do because you don't know what the [ __ ]
you think from day to day
that's why why do you think that though
because we're [ __ ] nominated because
we're stupid
because
that is true like like chemically like
every single day we are different
ugh
you have a whole bunch that's a hard to
swallow right that's a hard pill to
swallow so like i was saying earlier on
in the conversation right is that if if
we understand that your period makes you
a certain way right
and you know that it pisses off this is
a soft forget that we're not we're not
thinking about that we're thinking about
we're on the receiving end of the
emotion of the period
right that's what we're thinking
but we're still human beings too right
so as human beings we're going to
respond in kind
to being i guess uh
lambasted
when it's lambasted when it comes to the
period right and we we understand we
know you as an individual we're saying
but hang on do you not like this on a re
on the 30 other days of the of the month
but
generally like when it comes to this
time you're something different so we're
going to let you know that you've become
different
on this time but saying that seems to be
a problem
and we don't get that because if you
were to tell us
that we're different
we would understand actually you know
what actually guys
on these seven days we're we're acting a
little bit [ __ ] up like like we're
acting like we know we're actually
[ __ ] up but you don't want to be told
that
and that's what we don't understand i
think it's self-awareness comes into
play right um
[Music]
like i know that
chemically
if you think about it sometimes majority
of women are very
indecisive there's some that boom boom
boom can make a decision but it's
i understand what you're saying how many
times women i understand what you're
saying how women need to understand men
i think it's
there's when it comes to women like you
were saying chemically we are we think
different every day there may be a day
where we consecutively think the same
but
our bodies are going through a cycle for
30 plus days and it's a continuous thing
it's not something oh we just pause like
good i can think i can think properly i
can think clearly
it's
if you step outside of a woman's body if
you are a woman you step outside of your
body and you try to understand yourself
it's hard personally there's sometimes
i'm like
why why do i why do i do this why am i
thinking like this i'm trying to
understand when you cry over the
smallest thing i know
like what's going on i'm trying to
understand myself yeah and for men it's
just simple like that's what we do
that's how we live right yeah yeah yeah
don't understand like i
said i was saying this to be like kind
to you like i i don't understand why
yeah this way and so they're processed
and it comes out their mouth
you must be on your period and then
they'd be like
yeah everyone's like
don't say that why did they take it that
way i'm just trying to process and i
outwardly process and then
it comes into like okay maybe i'm not
going to say that anymore and it's just
like
they keep it inside and it's like
just both
no because well
well because i know i know this is very
i agree i know what she's saying she's
saying why would you do the same thing
if you get the same reaction every
single time you're right yeah like like
she's like why don't you keep doing it
if this is the
girl off
but women will do the same thing but
women will do the same thing expecting a
different reaction too
because you know it's been so long but
then
but then it's been at least 30 days
are you telling me that every 30 days
we've just got to be in our guard we're
just like but we're parents coming
we don't know what the [ __ ] going to
happen right now look at me i'm not
saying that's what you need to [ __ ]
expect but when you know the girls on
her thing like
why do you want to push well maybe they
button
[Music]
about men becoming more feminine right
yeah you are expecting men to act like
women
hang on women here women understand that
she's on a period yeah yeah she's
unknown
women understand that men don't get it
we have been here on this earth with
women
for hundreds of thousands of years and
we still do not get it stop asking us to
be like your girlfriend stop asking us
to be like women we are men for a reason
that's all we're saying we're men for a
reason and the thing is if we weren't
men
you wouldn't even be attracted to us
because you know what i'm saying
you wouldn't even be attracted to us if
you were men why would you even mention
our period because it's it's
we are logical processes
because he's saying like that's how
that's how men are is they just they're
like trying to fix a problem so this is
the problem you're upset about something
and they're thinking okay how do i fix
it let me rationalize this oh she's on
her you're probably just on your period
honey calm down don't tell me to calm
down
like
like that that's them trying to
rationalize it so you you asking him to
understand you that's that's asking him
to be more feminine because that's not a
feminine trait right so you see this
light right there that's not a masculine
there's a light here right
if the light goes out a man is trying to
fix the light yeah we're not trying to
understand why the light is gone or
what the what the light felt like yeah
when it was gone we're not trying to
we're just like that's gone fix it
that's how we think right and i'm not
saying it's the right thing or the wrong
thing i'm saying that's how we're wired
and so when we're wired a certain way
when you're asking us to be more like
women you can have that conversation
about your period and how you feel and
how you think with your other female
friends you know what i'm saying we
don't get it because because we are
trying to we're trying to just fix
things if you come to a man and say
oh my god at work today
this happened and i felt this way we're
listening and we're like
okay so we're gonna do about it
what's gonna happen like what what are
we doing to make you not feel like that
yeah and that's why but the thing is you
came to him
wanting to just vent and make make him
know how you feel yeah
does that make sense like we're trying
to fix it
you're trying to just express
we're trying to fix things and that's
why they're sometimes like are you sorry
okay
oh
you must be on your period because if
you're acting in a certain way they're
trying to understand it
and if you say
no i'm not on my peer then they're like
okay then let me try to figure out what
why is this like if you're if you've
acted this way like this every month on
your period and it's like oh you and
when we start seeing a pattern when we
start seeing that pattern we're like ah
all right she's on my appearance that's
what we're thinking
[Music]
but i think it
that well it honestly
in my last relationship it honestly like
helped because i would get [ __ ] like a
couple days before my period and he just
wouldn't really take it seriously
he's like oh she's just and at the time
at the time i'd be like mad i'd be like
take me seriously until like until like
three days later
and he's like oh she's just and then
like three days later i was like oh okay
sorry
the thing is we are okay with that as
long as you recognize that what's going
on
do you know what i'm saying like if you
recognize that you're feeling that way
because of your period we are okay with
that we're like
what is it i feel like it's a lot of
understanding
like as a woman i feel like even i've
seen this a lot of them like yeah okay
and i acknowledge it like if a man was
to check them about their menstrual
cycle and that's why that's what affects
their mood compared to if it's like
that's actually what they really
understand that that's what's really
affecting their mood that's really
what's taking an impact on their mood
do you know what i mean no i get it like
you can check me and i could know yeah
that's my messenger cycle but i'm still
going to be defensive
compared white to white white
i don't know why i can't explain to you
why
compared to a situation where it's like
that's a fact and where had she having a
conversation about me and my partner
do you know what i mean like getting
defensive about it because it's
different
like i feel like a lot of women don't
acknowledge it like understand no way a
lot of them don't understand it compared
to acknowledging it do you know what i'm
saying
i